everybody what's going on play here I'm
here in the Abe Lincoln museum in
Springfield Illinois for behind the
scenes of the Lincoln remote
[Music]
roll playback
nerdly of course not everyone comes
across valid
this below you sure Mary Poppins well we
know this is out there the whole book is
just one of the coolest parts this
museum is that they have an exact
replica of Abe Lincoln's cabin I'm
guessing where he grew up each one of
these trees is an exact replica of a
real tree down in the woods wherever
this actual cabin was seems like a
terrible waste of money
[Music]
so we are at the Capitol building I have
no idea what happened here could this I
didn't pay attention in school let's go
inside one kind of strange poster caught
my eye here at the old Statehouse
Lincoln your mind i awakes when he was
running on the maybe of nothing right
now do a nice thing i think the idea is
later the impersonators drinking with a
yes so any you guys can agree over here
and then you start fighting people that
will be fantastic something a little bit
about them they are all the 16th
President of the United States they're
all prone to depression and they're all
named England Lincoln this is kind of a
SP channel version of The Bachelorette
yeah
[Music]
one of my favorite things here that we
found is this a great century just even
a ductless one of Lincoln's political
rivals authorized entire life and he's
also known for having a small bladder
which is why he's kind of no beauty
now
be peeling off yeah I'm the camera
following me she's over there that's
good that's good okay good it's been a
fascinating experience I thought I knew
a lot about Abraham Lincoln but
apparently I didn't know what there are
four of them
[Music]
you
[Music]